it's really great to be in bergen this
is the second time this week i'm in
bergen
i live in oslo i guess i'm living in the
wrong place yeah
um as you quite rightly say my name
pellegrino which is my first name
means pilgrim it was given to me by my
italian parents
it's as if they knew what i was going to
do for the rest of my life
you know let's give him the name pilgrim
and then he'll travel the world and and
that's basically what i do this is my
workplace they do a lot of traveling
uh i could give you a fancy title of
what i do but what i really do is i try
to help people communicate
better especially in a global business
world
so i try to help people communicate
better with other nationalities
now you know the first thing you think
of when you work with other
nationalities in cross-cultural
communication is let's look at the other
cultures well i take a slightly
different approach
i say to people take a look at yourself
so i'm going to talk a lot about
perception because it's all about
perception understanding what people see
now as you say i have italian in me
i have a lot of british in me some
people are often surprised by my english
accent
it's quite nice isn't it yeah because
you weren't expecting this i know you
weren't you know you're expecting me to
speak with the italian accent yeah i
don't speak like that and i've been in
norway for over a third of my life
actually so i've got a lot of norwegian
in me as well and i love
what i like doing with people i have
these little social experiments
to test their perception of me now as i
say i travel a lot so
i i like playing with the airlines i
like going up to the airlines and
talking english or sometimes i talk with
an italian accent
to see what kind of reactions i get and
english is the best one if you want good
service you speak english like i do it's
fantastic people take you seriously
well they do you know i mean yesterday
the plane to bergen was late
you know and if i go up and say excuse
me that it's 30 minutes late i'm a
punctual person i don't like being late
you know they just take you seriously
but yesterday i thought i'd try it in an
italian accent
so i went up and and i actually said you
know uh excuse me but the plan is
started him in his life i'm a punctual
person you know
exactly i got the same reaction as you
did there
and this is one of the problems of
working with other nationalities you
know people see what they want to see
and they don't always see what you see
and this is this is this is one of the
challenges now just
before we get into it culture let's look
at culture culture my definition of
culture and i know this doesn't cover
everything
but let's keep it simple i usually do
two day workshops on this i've got 18
minutes
a system of behavior that helps us act
in an accepted or familiar way
key words there accepted or familiar
we're basically doing things which are
accepted in our social group and which
are familiar
so a lot of my work is actually
explaining norwegian
behavior to other nationalities so i'm
constantly looking for this sort of
can we describe a norwegian in a
nutshell and i think i found it i found
this fantastic text on the internet i
want you to read it with me it's really
it's worth reading it
uh if you were to use a color to
describe this person he would have to be
green
he lives in isolation in his home a
place he best describes as his and cozy
however he's not the most receptive of
people when it comes to visitors
okay the typical norwegian he is
somewhat primitive but he is honest
straightforward and all he really wants
in life are the simple little pressures
like peace and quiet do you recognize
any of this
there are some key words that kind of
can you say that they jump out at you
and you think okay it's a stereotype but
a lot of this is a bit true
and and i showed this to norwegians and
they kind of nod yeah okay okay i'll
give you that one
and then i surprise them this is a
description not of a norwegian but of a
hollywood film star
yeah would you like to know who it is
there it is it's that person there
and the point about this is you often
believe what people tell you as well you
know
i could sit there and tell you this is a
norwegian yeah yeah and you believe it
it's not a norwegian at all although
maybe this could be a norwegian there he
is going off to his house there
but there are many words in there which
are accepted and familiar accepted and
familiar now another accepted and
familiar thing about norwegian life is
the norwegian forest i live in the oslo
area it's all forest
and working across borders is
basically um you know not not not
accepting completely that your
assumptions are the assumptions of
others
i mean that's logic you know common
sense and the norwegian forest is a good
thing
isn't it norwegians in the room it's all
good it's fresh air it's nature it's
elks it's skiing it's fantastic
well that's what my wife thought the
first time my father visited us in
norway because she thought we would do
something nice
so my wife asked my italian father would
you like to go for a walk in the forest
and my father looked her and said why
and i had to explain to my wife that you
can't say to if you say to another
italian hey you or me we go for a walk
in the 40s
that means something else you don't do
that yeah but how can you know that you
know
because you know how could she know that
accepted and familiar you know at the
time we went for a drive we went for a
drive with my father
and we're all looking at the same thing
look at this you know beautiful
norwegian landscape
and my father's taking photographs you
know that he wants to show his friends
and the road is kind of bumpy so he says
to my wife um
could you slow the car down please stop
the car i want to take a proper
photograph and my wife says but mr
ricardi there's nothing here and
he looks at her and he says to her i
know i never seen nothing before but you
know
what was amazing with this is we're
looking at the same pictures and we're
using completely different words to
describe it and this is the challenge of
working across borders we've got
different ideas of accepted and familiar
here's what's accepted and familiar to
me when i queue
i was raised in the uk we are the world
champions of queueing waiting in line
and you know aren't we we're fantastic
yeah you know in if you're
waiting in line in a supermarket in the
uk let's say there are 10 people waiting
in line
and we're all getting a bit impatient
you know because we're all waiting in
line
and then they open a new cash register
do you know what will happen in the uk
the first four people they won't move
they'll stay in the queue the next six
people will move to the next cash
register
in more or less the same order and they
kind of check with each other
and if they open another cash register
the same will happen it's like a
formation dance it's fantastic
would the same happen in norway no what
would happen if they shout out in
norwegian it's lady custer which is a
available cash register what happens
everybody goes for it
it's first come first served isn't that
isn't that what's accepted and familiar
now the first time that happened to me i
was shocked
and i said some not very nice things
about norwegians
but you know it's it's you've got to dig
a bit deeper to find out why do
norwegians do that
why are they running for that cash
register why is it a free-for-all on
first come served
i think it's got to do with this what
they say this is the king of norway on a
train
in 1973 that guy in the cap on the right
this is equality and i think the queuing
system in norway is all about equality
first come first of
all is about equality and it's the
ability to dig
under the surface and find out what the
underlying values are
that's how you know how to communicate
with people and this thing with equality
is really important in a way
it's the reason we're so laid back with
each other we don't bother with titles
we dress casually it makes a fantastic
business environment actually
doesn't it but sometimes this can take
you a little bit by surprise and in
those situations where you feel
uncomfortable or
irritated we have a tendency to jump to
the negative conclusions
rather than the positive conclusions you
know and i mean i travel all over the
world
and i know you're not supposed to and
this isn't an advertisement for the
airlines but it's scandinavian airlines
and it's lufthansa and it's singapore
airlines and everybody knows that
singapore airlines has the best service
why because they have a whole lot more
hierarchy in their societies
and therefore when they serve you they
serve you and singapore airline staff i
don't know if you've ever been on the
singapore airlines flight but you just
just from the moment they welcome you
they look like they're going to serve
you don't they i mean it's just
the body language it's like anything for
you sir
now if a scandinavian airlines person
did this when you came on
but yeah exactly you would get
suspicious wouldn't you what's going on
because it's not accepted or familiar
that's it you know
this is what it's all about so this is
how we do it and look at the space
space is important nobody's touching and
if you go to somewhere like finland
that space becomes even more can you see
it look at that
it's fantastic and look at the way they
queue in france
there's nothing like the way i'm used to
queuing and it's different every day
it's never the same and in some cultures
you need a bit more
motivation to stand in line and this is
my favorite one this is fantastic look
at this
isn't that great they're all different
we're all doing the same thing in
slightly different ways
now how do you get across borders how do
you how do you navigate
through this because you can't learn all
the codes it's impossible
here's a tip this is what i'm really
passionate about curiosity
i am have been always will be a curious
person
curiosity gets you through a lot of
things i believe you can ask
any question to anybody about just about
anything
provided you do it with curiosity that's
it
and curiosity is a great thing now i've
got three kids
they're you know kids are the most
curious creatures on the planet a recent
survey i read i don't know if i believe
this but i have to quote it apparently
four-year-olds will ask up to 390
questions per day
82 of those questions will be to mothers
rather than fathers you know why because
when the kid goes to the father what
does the father say
go and ask your mother yeah yeah you
know curiosity is so important you know
and
and i remember the time you know one of
the most difficult situations i had i
was
having a meal in helsinki in finland and
i was sitting there and the thing is
italians when we eat
we talk we have to talk actually we eat
and we talk we eat and we talk and we're
not alone on that actually there are
many cultures that do that
finns on the other hand don't have to
talk
they can talk but they don't have to so
i'm sitting next to this fin
and i'm trying to be curious and create
conversation and i thought okay small
talk the rules of engagement of small
talk rule number one ask a simple
question
curious simple question rule number two
listen to the answer
pick out a word follow up that word it's
really simple actually
so i was there and this quiet thing was
sitting next to me and i turned to him
and i said
um so have you lived in helsinki all
your life and he looked at me a little
strangely and said
not yet
moments like this you know which word do
i follow up on not
to yet you know they really challenge
your curiosity but you've got to be
curious and it's really simple do you
know what it is about the nordic
cultures it's all about economy of
language
you know italians use loads and loads of
words
to say very very little actually in the
nordic countries it's different it's the
opposite it's minimum words maximum
message right so where i was raised in
the uk
the uk is also lots of words by the way
look at this
excuse me may i just interrupt you for a
second that's ten words
that's way too many words the norwegians
managed to do this in one word
now that's what i call economy of
language what's the word
look at this yeah do that's it
here's another example look sorry for
bumping into you like that terribly
clumsy of me that's way too many words
the norwegians do it in one word ready
there he goes fantastic
and my favorite and you know the answer
sorry i didn't quite catch what you just
said
well done ha one word now the first time
i heard that i just heard this you see
i've got three kids now going
but look beyond the negative side and
look to the curiosity
and this is it we're often misperceived
because on a serious note this
ha which i've heard many times doesn't
often get perceived very positively by
other nationalities
you get it yeah and everyone has been
misperceived in their life i mean the
dutch
are often misperceived they complain a
lot they are the world champions of
complaining the dutch
but why do they do it they do it because
they're looking for something better and
one way you do it is to complain
and seek a better result that's often
difficult
i used to work with a guy who was french
he is french i used to work with him his
name was eve
eve eve complained a lot as well he he
complained about everything and he
questioned everything he had a fantastic
mind you know i would come into work and
once i came into work and i said to eve
good morning and he looked at me and he
said
is it i mean he was on that level you
know
and and i've had my challenges too i've
had my challenges too the biggest
challenge i've had
uh living in norway and trying to
communicate with my fellow norwegians is
of course this thing with feelings and
expressing feelings you know where i
come from
we express um what i've learned to do
i've had to learn to do is kind of tone
myself down actually
living in the nordic countries you know
living in order tone myself down
keep it low keep it calm because that
works better
which is often very very difficult yeah
another thing is rules i've found rules
i still find rules a little tricky i
must admit that's where i'm quite
italian
now these are people driving into work
in a town in oz in in norway they're
following rules can you see
and they're simple rules the rules are
keep between the lines
and don't use that lane over there
that's the public transport lane unless
you're a buster taxi or an electric car
simple rules and look at this every
single car manages to drive between the
lines it's fantastic
now this is a little clip that i took
this summer driving down to italy
this is a police car that car has got
nothing to do with the police car
uh and it's just a little short clip
here but you know look at him i mean
would you do that
in norway you know you wouldn't you know
you wouldn't huh
and this is another clip in france what
they do
yeah yeah look what what happens is you
see is that they drift
i love that guy in the bmw did you see
that the french guy are you going left
or right there dude not not yet they've
not disabled
it's fantastic and then some countries
here you can't even see the lines
where are the lines where are they you
know
and i suggested once to an indian
colleague of mine perhaps if you painted
the lines more regularly
people would follow the rules and he
just said no that would be a waste of
paint you know so
that's why we have traffic wardens
that's why we have traffic orders in
norway this is a traffic warden in
norway giving a ticket a fine to this
car now
i'm just going to check you see
norwegians know these rules
instinctively you kind of
it's your duty to learn the rules but
can i ask you why is that car going to
get a fine
why is he going to get a fine too close
to the zebra crossing the pedestrian
crossing
what's the minimum distance and people
mumbling five hours
you know this stuff it's like a stupid
question so the day i park my car
in oslo let me just explain what's going
on you see the line goes under here and
then underneath the wheel this is no
parking i was in a little bit of a hurry
and my wife said to me i think you
should move your car forward a little
bit
i said why just just move your car it's
you'll get a fine why just just just
please move your car
you could see she was really
uncomfortable you know and this
irritated me i thought you know i
haven't got time for this
let's go so i left okay and this is
especially for the norwegians in the
room
did i get a fine do you feel sorry for
me
no you get no sympathy no sympathy
whatsoever you know
it's a simple bloody rule follow the
rules you know
now italians believe that the power
of speech the power of persuasion is
your most important tool in life
we believe that you can appeal to people
and if you're good enough appealing
they might listen to you and they might
find an alternative solution so
i believed that i could call the oslo
traffic
police and talk my way out of a problem
and i can see norwegians doing this or
not you're wasting your time
don't bother no i thought i would try so
i called the guy down at the oslo
traffic
hello this is pellegrino by the way i
spoke english of course
not norwegian because they take it more
seriously yeah
hello this is uh referring to case 78206
yes i have it in front of me here listen
i was just wondering if we could be a
little bit flexible on this i mean we're
only talking about 20 centimeters i'm
really sorry i've learned my lesson i
won't ever do it again that kind of
stuff
did it help not at all
to his credit he was good he was really
good i could hear him clicking in the
background he had all the rules he was
saying i'm very sorry but you know the
wheel must be inside the box
it says here in the rule five paragraph
d he had all the answers in front of him
yeah and then he said something i'll
never forget he said to me
riccardi is your name you may be italian
well it's a you probably like football i
said i do like football well it's like
football you know the ball must be over
the line the wheel must be on the ball
it's fantastic now
it was great he had all the answers
black and white you know he had
everything
fine so i told my friend eve this my
friend eve the french guy
who got really irritated remember eve is
it
but he's really good at asking questions
and he said okay the wheel must be
inside the box he said what if i take
the wheel off the car what would
happen then i thought that was really
interesting actually
what would happen so i called back and
asked him what would happen if i took
the wheel off the box
he didn't have an answer for me he
couldn't answer that question
why not because it's not an accepted and
familiar question and he doesn't have
that approach
then you need the help of an italian
because the time i parked my car in
italy
you see i was looking for a parking
place on holiday impossible
i see a traffic ward and i go up to her
and i start talking in italian and i say
listen i'm looking for a parking place
and she says
there is a parking house nearby but
don't park your car there
why not she says it's too expensive
forty euro really what should i do and
she says i like you seem like a nice
fellow
i like you i like the way you talk
italian i'm going to help you today she
says park your car over there and she
points over to this sign
and says go and park your car
come on i can't believe it's okay it's
not dangerous park your car
don't pay for the auro in the parking
hours park your car over there i give
you a fine for 30 euro you save yourself
10 euros
now
i'm not here to discuss whether it's
right or wrong
but what i can tell you is that i get it
i get it because i've got it inside me
i've seen this before and i accept it
and i can see the positive elements you
see
these three cultures i have inside me
just to finish off this is what i'm
passionate about
i've got three cultures inside me and
they're all very different their planets
apart
they really are in certain aspects but
you know what i try to do on a daily
basis especially with my kids
i try to take the best of all three take
the best of all three
and try to merge them into one
one new culture where you take the best
of all three
across borders isn't about going across
borders in my mind it's about
extending your borders and creating new
ones around us and you know what if you
can create a new culture where you take
the best of all three
like i tried to do and it's not easy
guess what
that's when you create what we call a
global mindset
and i believe this is what makes the
world go round
thank you very much